si louise forestier bienvenue à la
chaîne musicale louise forestier je suis
tombé sous le charme de votre émission à
la chaîne musicale de radio-canada
cette série commence avec une belle
tranche de vie vous avez 4 5 1 votre
maison brûle vous allez chez le voisin
et lui un homme qui entre avec une
guitare félix leclerc il chante le
sentiment d'en ressortir
je vous en dirais que c'est un signe
pour que vous consacrez votre votre vie
à la musique
la vie est pas mal plus fine que nous
sommes souvent alors là l'été film quand
félix leclerc est rentrée chez son frère
ce jour là c'était quelque chose
les payes ton poli et implique sa voix
sa voix profonde goethe appuyé sur sa
jambe ou sa cuisse mccaw j'avais comme
tout le son de la guitare savoie
directement sur moi
il n'oublia bécanthy venu au il est venu
chanter des années plus tard j'étais un
versification au collège livre de
chanter j'étais de voir l'un coulisses
il m'a regardé puis 10 mais c'est la
petite bellehumeur ce sont bien nos huit
bellehumeur de montréal s'ils marquent
nos jeux et marc a connu ce chien tombé
après le collège vous a eu vos débuts à
les connaissiez le théâtre de belles
images dans nos archives 1965
vous hésitiez comédienne chanteuse mais
vous avez vu la place des arts peter
paul mary chan téva vendredi mayence
vous étiez ouvreuse ouais ça c'était
aussi un gros des clés que vous les avez
même rencontre oui après le spectacle
j'ai une culot de frapper à la porte de
la loge de mairie qui m'a reçue
gentiment je dois c'est un beau
spectacle
j'aime bien vous dire que j'ai décidé
grâce à vous de devenir une chanteuse
serait qu'à madiot vallée fêter ça on
est au queen elizabeth may vous avec
peter paul mary on est parti boire
on a parlé jusqu'à 2 heures du matin de
ce que c'était que le métier et ça ça
m'a donné
mais
mais votre destin est intrinsèquement
lié à celui robert charlebois pendant
toute mon adolescence j'ai écouté en
boucle california le blog
d'où vous est venue cette idée d
contrechamp je sais pas si c'est arrivé
comme ça quand il s'est mis à composer
la musique qu'on avait la feuille de
theix et puis comme si tu as un avion
[Musique]
comme tout
je dis tiens joue enfin fly et ma voix
ça va devenir l'avion qui conduite par
lindbergh le grain pilotes alors ce saut
j'ai fait j'ai fait l'avion ce
californien
[Musique]
tous nous d'où ça vient d y avait un
groupe à l'époque où il y avait beaucoup
qui jouait de la flûte proton joueurs
pour manger flottant leçons de l'afflux
de cette épopée
ça m'est revenue car le poignet j'ai
faisons cette amitié avec robert
charlebois il a vraiment demeurer rester
dans ta on a en mémoire
yvon robert mot fait moi un moment
unique magique où la chanson québécoise
complètement environnement avec le stick
[Musique]
et ça c'est inoubliable al assad père
qui a sonné comme une caire une caste à
part c'est aux autres mais c'est vrai et
je vous dis aux deux de ses membres
l'océanie qui m'appelle la nuit à 3
heures du matin je ne pourrai jamais ne
pourrait pas jamais je préfère la mort à
toute complicité
on a parlé beaucoup des années soixante
mais soixante dix détourné y extrait de
chanter la chanson thème oui il ya de
l'écho d'un peuple qui ne sait pas quoi
esprit montre qu'on est 10 fois roy oui
tout ce qu'un certain vous est
totalement étourdis par la carrière que
vous oubliez de plex tenir les livres de
relier la mort mais je n'avais pas de
j'avais peu de temps ça voulait
tellement j'étais tout le temps imparti
que jamais chez moi j'ai eu mon premier
saut fort à 50 est crise pour voter je
ne pouvais pas me poser une part c'était
au jour d'un voyage alors d'un disque à
l'autre écrit quand tu écris ton
matériel en plus faut du temps pour
écrire puis bon thormann faut être quand
on a enfin ne va pas ça prend du temps
alors j'ai un pote en meublé ma maison
pour 2021 je vous souhaite la musique de
la radio la télévision des films
l'écriture
au l'écriture beaucoup j'écris ce fait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mardi
ici